d'autres sujets le navigateur louis
burton était à coignières aujourd'hui le
skipper avec jusqu'à l'âge de 17 ans à
la selle les bornes près de rambouillet
il a appris à naviguer au centre de vol
de 50 ans on devine avec son sponsor
bureau vallée il va à la rencontre des
clients et des passionnés de sports
nautiques
oui dortona déjà réalisé la route du
rhum la jacques vabre il participera
pour la deuxième fois à la prochaine
course du vendée globe ou l'écoutent au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
heures au vendée globe 2012 jeu on
s'attendait pas à ça je m'attendais pas
à ce que ça s'arrête au bout de cinq
jours c'est une préparation très longue
c'est beaucoup d'investissement donc
c'est toujours très bizarre quand ça
s'arrête si vite donc voilà là je parle
on est confiant je suis serein avec le
bateau maintenant je sais aussi que un
vendée globe c'est c'est quelque chose
qui se
qui doit se mériter de gagner et que
rien n'est fait tant qu'on n'a pas
bouclé le parcours et pour la 8e édition
du vendée globe le départ sera donné le
6 novembre 2016 en baie des sables
d'olonne